impossible for a plain yellow pumpkin to
become a golden carriage
impossible brandy's performance at
cinderella made a
lasting impact on a generation this is
my dream and it's come true
i finally get to work with whitney and
while whitney houston was memorable as
her fairy godmother
she originally wanted to play the
princess herself
and later decided the glass slipper
might fit better
on someone else it took four years to
bring this project together yeah
and i stuck with this project for four
years and um
um until i decided that i wasn't even i
wasn't going to be cinderella
and that i would be the fairy godmother
who are you
i'm your fairy godmother honey you
you got a problem with that brandy was
definitely handpicked by me
i definitely wanted her to be cinderella
well she called me
and asked me if i would be cinderella
and that was a big thing for me because
i really i was really excited about the
movie and everything so
when she called me i just was abs all i
can remember was
ah you know i remember that
mama she wants me to play cinderella
fabulous
me do you see anybody else in this room
it was a groundbreaking casting for the
fairy tale
the 18 year old actress became the first
black cinderella portrayed on screen
i've always dreamed to be some type of
animated disney character
and and to be the first african-american
cinderella that's
that's history that's never been done
before oh i wish that
but i guess wishing's not good either
everything starts with a wish
i can't even when they told me that the
sets were beautiful i never thought that
beautiful meant
all of this disney went all in for this
major tv event
providing cinderella with a 12 million
dollar budget
it's pretty pretty big for television
man somebody's writing some great checks
at disney
brandi invited e.t to share the moment
of when she first got a look at the
movie's incredible sets
and her reactions they were priceless oh
my god
this has got to go into me
i feel like cinderella right now let's
practice
look at the piano
[Music]
are still inside my hand
it's original rogers and hammerstein yes
oh you don't mess with rnh
[Laughter]
there will be no messing with rnh e.t
was in the recording studio
when brandy and whitney sang their
iconic duet
and won't believe what sensible people
say
and because these stuffed and dewy eye
dopes keep building up
impossible impossible things are
happening every
day i've always wanted to sing with
some of the people that i've looked up
to like whitney and just to be in the
studio with her
so i just give it all i have give it all
i got
i was wondering about the ball this is
the most amazing thing i've ever seen in
my entire life
i have to see this movie you do please
watch it november 2nd abc everything is
great
hollywood boulevard was blocked off for
cinderella's premier bash
which made way for brandy and paolo's
majestic
carriage ride entrance oh my god i'm so
excited i'm so excited this is the
greatest moment in my whole life
it's too much it's all too much for me
whitney and brandy gave e.t their
reaction
after seeing the finished movie standing
ovation
applause after every song you guys must
feel fabulous right now
how you feel honey i feel fabulous i
feel fabulous
isn't it everything that you dreamed it
would be sitting in there tonight
yeah and more really proud of her
she did so good cinderella was a smash
hit
the broadcast premiere received over 60
million viewers
when the movie went to home video the
following year cinderella sold a million
video cassettes in just
the first week it's unbelievable to me i
grew up watching
brandy be the first black cinderella on
television the movie was beloved by a
generation
and even led to another groundbreaking
casting for the fairy tale
in 2014 kiki palmer became the first
black cinderella on broadway
and she said her love of brandy's
performance brought the moment full
circle
i get to play one of the most iconic
princesses of
our lifetime and it never really
occurred to me
you know that i would be the first black
cinderella on broadway i mean and brandy
is like
my girl like anybody that knows me they
know i have looked
up to brandi since i was a kid and so
for me this moment is
is is an aw moment for so many reasons
and kiki is just one of the millions who
was touched
by a role that whitney knew would be
remembered forever
aren't you coming with me i got you to
the ball
the rest comes from you we all just
believed in this project that it was
going to be incredible and that it was
going to mean something to a whole lot
of
children especially children there are
great messages
in cinderella that i don't think people
really got that you'll see in this one
i mean they really come to life anything
is possible
if you believe in yourself that
dreaming is just a dream if you don't
put it into effect
if you don't make it happen if you don't
work your show if you don't handle your
business if you don't move you know
it doesn't become anything
you